if you're thinking about a career in
cyber security the job outlooks stronger
than ever according to the Bureau of
Labor Statistics the number of people
employed within that sector slated to
grow some 31 percent over the next five
years CSN has joined a national effort
by Microsoft to expand its cyber
security programs
millions of jobs to the tune of three
million jobs by the year 2025 will be
centered on these these particular areas
and so if our colleges and our
universities don't get out of theory and
into practical elements of how to create
cyber Security Professionals then we're
we're gonna we're gonna slip in a very
very bad spot but CSN is in a very good
space as VP of academic Affairs Dr James
McCoy the Department of Homeland
Security and NSA have recognized csn's
cyber security program as a national
Center of academic Excellence it will
receive twenty thousand dollars to
further that initiative McCoy says this
funding will allow CSN to focus on
diversifying the student population and
get students into high-skilled
high-paying jobs right now we're really
proud that about 21 of our cyber
security I.T students are female that
beats the national average and certainly
the state average at 17 but that's not
enough we've got a lot more attraction
points McCoy says CSN is looking to
expand the cyber security program beyond
the two-year degree to a four-year
Bachelors of applied science degree the
additional education helping students
become even stronger job candidates when
we've talked to employers they've all
said that was amazing for the few
Learners that we put through it already
nothing but positive feedback Professor
Arthur solman has been teaching students
at CSN for the past 10 years he says
this funding will ultimately help
students boost their confidence and
competence it's not just do I understand
the theory behind ABC but can I as an
entry-level worker do ABC can I go to an
employer and be like hey this is what
I've done and I can show you I can prove
to you that I have these confidence
skills
CSN is also currently revamping its
physical Network room it has a class
that's a hundred percent Hands-On
putting students into scenarios with
real equipment to run through as if it's
a real business